yep that's me just another heterosexual
male in the world who went out and
watched Magic Mike it's not weird Magic
Mike
now Magic Mike starts Channing Tatum who
used to be a stripper I guess and
immediately I was like okay if porn
taught us one thing is that good acting
does not come from strippers so the plot
is Channing Tatum works a lot of odd
jobs out there they all pay in cash and
he runs across this one young guy who's
kind of down on his luck he doesn't
really have a job so he kind of
befriends him he gets him into a club
and then he gets him into his work which
is a male strip club and then he goes
out there onstage and they all like him
so now he's in so now it's really a
movie about him being a male stripper
and Channing Tatum being a male stripper
which sounds really stupid a lot of
people are like why did you watch this
movie I'll tell you why cuz it was
surprisingly enjoyable bear with me
first of all it's directed by Steven
Soderbergh I didn't know that the dude
who directed Ocean's eleven directed
this movie holy and yeah he did I
knew something was up cuz I was like
this movie is better than it should be
in fact I'm gonna say it's actually
enjoyable and good who directed this so
I looked it up and there we are I mean
the characters were actually
surprisingly good Channing Tatum I
actually liked in this movie I didn't
like him as a stripper all right I got
to rephrase that
I really do I thought he was just going
to be good as a stripper in the sense
that he used to be a stripper in real
life so he'd know the moves and that's
how he worked for this movie that's
phrased well I think but I actually
enjoyed him as a person and a character
in this movie he was actually good he
had some good lines some good dialogue I
liked his personality and he was talking
with the young dudes sister I was like I
don't like her and I like the way he
talks to her oh yeah speaking of her all
right I'm gonna touch on this chick I
couldn't stand her I don't know what it
is I think it's actually the actress
because she just never looks happy she
always has this pissed-off Bella look in
her face you want a drinking game here's
an unfunny make a shot every time she
smiles when Channing Tatum's not in the
scene yeah you'll be stone sober by the
time it's done because Channing Tatum is
the only one who ever makes her smile
which I guess works for what they have
going on but it didn't made me I'm like
come on I don't like you enjoy anything
at all and I'll be fine I'm Matthew
McConaughey plays the owner of this male
strip club he's like the Maria Bello of
coyote ugly in this movie and he was
good yet this like strong personality
was eva's Matthew McConaughey you could
swear the guy was probably a male
stripper in real life also another
really strong supporting character who
you can almost argue that the movie
revolves around but it doesn't it's
called Magic Mike he was pretty good but
I feel like anyone could have played him
but in the end of the movie you're like
well his problems still exist I mean
Channing Tatum kind of result his
but that guy might be dead in the gutter
next week and I don't think we're
supposed to care kind of found that odd
like a character right now don't give a
about it well you know it is a
movie about male strippers directed by
Steven Soderbergh it actually makes it
look like there's this weird subculture
in male stripping I don't know I feel
like a lot of people are gonna apply to
be male strippers you know because
they're like that looks awesome and
they're gonna have no credit and no
experience for a job when they're 40 and
their life's gonna suck ass it does
touch on that in this movie too so at
least there is that hey of all you're in
your twenties there's no other kind of
people that regularly go to male strip
clubs they're not sorority chicks just
being honest with you the other male
strippers in this place you're like well
they're just kind of in the background
they don't have any real characters
they're there to be male strippers
because it was just a male strip club
that had two male strippers that would
be odd however also you devote from
truebloods in it and that that is one
attractive bastard I'm serious I'm gonna
be honest with you guys you know chicks
usually like that chicks hot I hate her
now that's a good-looking dude and men
if I were gay I'd hit that
so Magic Mike surprised the hell out of
me I walked out of a gun alright did
anyone else enjoy that movie and they
were like yeah it was a lot better than
it should have been could've been would
have been but like a roomful of people
who all felt weird for saying they liked
the movie but ultimately they liked the
movie so did I I will say Magic Mike is
a surprisingly good time no alcohol
required yeah we live in a world where
the female stripper movie sucks ass and
the male stripper movie is actually
enjoyable yes 2012 is actually the end
of the world but hey for nothing else
they try to counteract any and all man
thongs and banana hammocks with a
topless Olivia Munn scene at the
beginning of the movie and that's just
not a bad attempt that that's it's not
bad there are worse things that could
have done so what do I ask you what your
favorite stripper movie is no one has a
favorite who is the actress chick with
no personality in any movie that you've
seen do is she comment below let me know
it's the best I can doing here and as
always if you like what you seen here
and you want to see more click right
here to see more
you
[Music]